I'm so open and so fragile that like I
feel like the world just like permeates
me all the time and that results in
anxiety and depression and like
confusion and loneliness and like ups
and downs Wow
duh so good to see you virtually yeah
how are you doing right now with
everything kind of going on how are you
feeling about everything I was like
right now I always feel like when I see
you I'm like let's talk about it I feel
like my interviews with you are the most
like emotive yeah you like it's pretty
it's a it's a weird time for everybody I
feel like it's pretty up and down for
everybody today I feel fine you know I
feel like it's a day-to-day experience
like I think two days ago I had like a
massive breakdown and it was like humans
aren't meant to be cooped up you know I
mean I feel like this is like an
ultimate experience of like you can't
really distract yourself from yourself
so I think that that affects everybody
differently yeah I think it's making all
of us feel more present and kind of like
in touch with ourselves and in touch
with loved ones because you're forced to
communicate from like a distance and
FaceTime and zoom and it's weird it's a
weird time for sure where are you right
now and who are you with I'm in my house
yeah my boyfriend is is here we're
quarantine and we live together so
recording him together and our two cats
oh I love that well I know today's a big
day I do want to talk about this new
song remember me so please
[Music]
I saw on Twitter you said it's about
yourself so kind of walk me through the
inspiration behind it and and why why
you chose this as the next single yeah I
recorded this song like I nearly two
years ago and it's about me in the sense
that every song even if it is a love
song is still about me because I've
always felt it's actually so funny Emma
Watson recently came out and said that
she was self partnered is that what she
said yeah yeah I love that by the way
yeah and I have always written in my
journal like years and years and years
ago I was like no matter who I find no
matter who I'm with
whether it's like incredible or worst I
always will have the knowledge that I am
my own partner I am my own caregiver my
own parent my own other half I complete
me and I think that that is why every
love song while it's about the
relationship it's also about me you know
it's about my own expression of love and
my experience of love and really more so
about my it's so funny you know you
choose your partner because they are
good with you they choose you choose
your partner because they are sometimes
a reflection of you or what you you know
need or what you want or what you love
or you admire it's all to do with you
right so I mean while it's also
completely to do with them because
that's what love is you know falling in
love with this like incredible separate
other that you're like wow I can't
believe something like you can exist
it's like it's a cosmic experience to
fall in love and so in the end
everything's about you so yeah it is
about me
it's interesting because to me you have
such like a clean image and you do come
from the Disney background but your
music is becoming more and more edgy in
the word that I speak to you I realize
how mature you actually are so I'm
wondering what what parts of you
you want us to really recognize an
agenda so she ate you know yeah you're
so lovely to talk to are you so funny
because like I see myself as the least
clean image person ever like I don't
know where people get this from I
understand that I have a Disney
background completely get that like
that's like separate I know that that
brand is a very clean grant as it always
has been as it should be a clean brand
thing I have no idea where it came from
I think that I when I was younger I
wanted to be you know everybody wants to
be beautiful everybody wants to be liked
everybody wants to be the best version
of themselves but I don't think I ever
attempted to be like clean I think it
was more I wanted to keep so much of
what is culturally considered not clean
I wanted to keep so much of that to
myself I'm so open and so fragile that
like I feel like the world just like
permeates me all the time and that
results in anxiety and depression and
like confusion and loneliness and like
ups and downs with being like wow I want
it oh my god I feel so safe I want to
eat it all I want to meet you all I want
to look and I'm like oh my god just
kidding I need to shave my head and move
away and like never talk to anyone ever
again but it feels like that kind of
like every couple days you know and so I
kind of really have to like regulate
myself and and pay attention to that I
think this culture is so insidious for
what is allowed for a woman especially
like a developing young woman and I
think I wanted my boyfriend to think I
was like good you know I wanted my
boyfriend to think I was like beautiful
and pure and like whatever like I wasn't
like a bad girl cuz like bad girls get
punished you know like it was very much
like a a cultural like I was just trying
to like survive within like this very
thin parameters of the culture yeah and
I think as I've gotten older I'm like I
mean get like I'm like I don't I don't
like that like I don't like that that
exists I don't subscribe to it I know if
you if you work that way I don't care to
please you and it really took me a long
time to stop feeling so bad about
self that I needed the approval of
everybody and to start being like I
really only care about my own approval
and I don't want to be on my deathbed
wishing I had expressed myself in all of
my entirety for what that means to me
not for other people right so yeah
really changed everything do you feel
like this music then is your way of sort
of self-expression and letting us figure
out who you are as a person in your
current state and agent laughs yeah I
think I'm I'm also attempting to figure
out who I am and the music is really
helpful because it's very visceral and
it's very like emotive so it's easy for
me to rather than like try to put
something that can't be verbalized and
intellectualized into a sort of the
sound bite it's easier for me to be like
oh this is how I feel rather because I
think a lot of people think that's like
celebrities or artists or actors have
like defined something that they want to
communicate and I don't always finding
ourselves but as I find myself like I do
I do really want that to be something
that I feel is authentically received I
don't need people to see me in any sort
of certain way as much as I just want
people to give everybody including me
and themselves and everyone around them
room to be authentic and messy and
incomplete like still forming yeah let's
talk about the guest feature on this
track how did that come about and why
would she kind of like the perfect
person to be part of this song um we
never intended to have a feature on this
song so like I said we recorded it like
two years ago and it was always one of
our favorites me us meaning like the
label and and me and as we got further
along the road and decided that Remember
Me was going to be the next single they
floated the idea of passing me about a
future
and I I was like I don't I'm not I'm not
completely sold that it needs a feature
let me hear what you guys want to do
with it and then like we'll go from
there yeah submitted and she just really
stood out and her tone and her lyricism
and the sort of like energy that she
brought to the track was so cohesive
with what was already there and I just
felt like she elevated it I loved her as
a person I think she's so like smart and
lovely and vivacious and like a girl's
girl and creative and talented and I
just really loved her like bonded being
like you know like to to women really
just like I just really I'm really
feeling the feminine energy right now
and I'm really happy that she's a part
of my music was there or is there a
music video plan for this or was that
kind of halted because of what's
happening right now yeah they're there
so I hi I planned a music video that
they approved of all of the all of the
visual aspects I'm very much like
involved in oh yeah a hundred like I'm
I'm so controlling when it comes back
like my labels literally like shut up
and I'm like I don't care but yeah I I
had this music video planned then
everybody really liked we just ran out
of time because I was I was off shooting
a movie and then we went on lockdown but
the lyric video that came out today is
very much based on my original idea for
the music video um so if you see that
you're kind of like you'll kind of get
the vibe but it's just sort of that
nostalgic overly Icona sized you know
fom fat all villainous beauty kind of
theme and like a darker love kind of
it's very aesthetic and I hope we get to
film a music video we're trying to find
ways around obviously like we're trying
to do everything we're not gonna do
anything until it's safe to do anything
but but we'll see
[Music]